ready welcome to worth it UK you getting
bad points a lot of noise in general
yeah welcome to worth it yeah this week
Jesus there's a lot of bagpipe noises
that matter bagpipes are good yeah
welcome to worth it UK a show where we
tried three different foods at
drastically different price but so were
drastically seems like a weird you'd say
whenever you want
I would never usually even say the word
dress it up again elephant in the room
it's not Stephen Adam and Andrew sitting
here with the UK kind of knock-offs
so bear with us I'm Joe I are did it
sound right the magic of this show is to
try three foods at drastically different
price points to determine which is the
most well good this week we are tasting
Britain's favourite foods courage curry
fish and chips
right guys our first stop is why cross
street market in East landed tunic up
mate but why cost rate average what's
what cross street market it is the
oldest market in London my name is Jess
I'm here at yko Street this is my stall
and it's called a crooner where did the
known Perona come from my mother helped
a lot initially to start off the
business and her name's Aruna I've been
at work retreat
around 17 years from one of the longest
standing traders here now so we
specialize in Indian Street food we
basically do three different vegetarian
curries every day the word masala is our
source yep basically that's exact what
is you've got tomato puree human got the
coriander powder turmeric chili powder
garam masala so that's the basic mix you
can formulate that into each individual
curry today you'll be having the gobby
mutter
cauliflower MP a split lentil toe Kadam
Bombay potato what a bit of rice at four
pounds
it looks pound fine it looks really good
look how colorful it is it's like a
rainbow remember the ice creams you'd
get as a kid that was the three colors
this is like the curry version
Neapolitan three-in-one with some side
switches fuses that's got I'm gonna
sweat a bit so really good were you
making it than plain s or Helen arms or
John a napkin um no yeah maybe it's
perfect on the spice factor no you know
I don't like too much spice makes my
nose run but you've got the cauliflower
you've got the rice as well that kinda
adds what you would be missing in the
meet the lentil gets a good 10 are 10
for me oh yeah really impactful flavor I
would say um yeah so poofy Curry's
definitely it's like each part of the
meal is a different part of town and
you're sort of going through one to the
other
that's why this is such a good dish what
you got there Borden either wow you can
barely get the lid on when we got it
it's filled to bursting four pounds I
don't know what more we could ask for
oh you don't have their joke
[Music]
Co fact curry FAC London contains more
Indian restaurants in Mumbai and Delhi
combined
really is that true so did you get that
one from that well then that's obviously
not true and now we are off to Brick
Lane yes sir Brick Lane has some of the
most curry houses in London it's really
one of London's sort cultural hotspots
and my career was born not quite where
cars born you do know where curry
originated only career
[Music]
[Music]
my name is Ronnie we're nozzle this is
the oldest restaurant in Brooklyn so bad
atmosphere is so bad food is bad quality
the traditional dishes these are like
Madras bean how they cook in India how
they cook in Bangladesh how they cook in
Kashmir but in our chefs opportunities
from chef secrets he can't even tell me
if I go up a kitchen and ask him that's
the secret
and you get all the ingredients fresh
yeah nothing is precooked everything is
grilled marinated first tuna tandoori
oven he makes his own sauce and he
prepared it from his version this
sweet-and-sour little bit of kick but
it's not spicy it's not gonna burn your
tongue you'll be having chicken tikka
blast of 1595 my foods more ground there
is cool and the multicolored rice is
just awesome this is the well-presented
mill I like it oh my god did think of
something at a bar after that saw
cinnamon's it's very simple everyone
should tear their own bunch of terrorism
that was really nice good it's not hot
it's just a nice little flicker of spice
right yeah what I really like about is
it's actually quite sweet as well I
think I could eat a lot of this just bar
you got a happier than Indian fellow
yeah of course
I feel like the Maury there's more
discover about what's in it yeah I mean
it's actually quite complex there's been
a lot of love and care gone into the
preparation of that chicken and you can
really really taste it give us a Charles
just description of what the suits me
wrong like it just tastes like having a
great time with good people like know it
mean go what you turn nice right over
your side yeah but you don't scoop scoop
on your side you have I haven't drive
into that one Joe you got anymore my
facts there no pokhara joke
my granddad had an accident he curry
yeah he slipped into a corner once it he
ended up next to my right that's enough
of that our final stop is in Mather
swanky also they need a week's prep time
to make this masterpiece
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we are at Benares restaurant and my name
is arthur kosher chef patron of this
restaurant we won a Michelin star in
2007 and it's almost 10 years we have
maintained it well ours menu is always
about what's happening around at the
moment in this particular month I
strongly believe our ethos are if we let
mother nature do the job really well as
a cook I would have to do very little
today you'll be tasting truffle and
mushroom and saffron culture which has a
stuffed non so to speak which will be
smothered with gold leaf butter and then
it's drizzled with single estate
balsamic vinegar which is really really
fantastic and this will be served with
venison keema
starting with garam masala and we say
garam masala add cinnamon cardamom clove
and then add saute onion and garlic put
the meat in and then when we finish it
with a little bit of tomato at that time
just to thicken the keema really handful
of chocolate that chocolate actually
makes the sauce and morel mushrooms
which are really at the peak at the
moment so flavors would be humongous and
really big and that is the most
exclusive dish on a menu we sell it for
210 pounds I'm ready so am i this is an
incredibly exciting moment I am so
pumped wealth just emanating from this
dish it really is something else to look
at Jordan has obviously dressed for the
occasion
I was gonna say we should tear but
they've provided us with a weapon cut
this into four four pieces so we can
have two each
and your body Cheers
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
it's just really it's like a parade
there's just all this fancy ass food
going on tall for your mouth but
chucking out venison and chucking out
bits of gold still like a curry with nan
bread it's just a really really special
courier nerd bread can you taste the
gold that truly is the definition of
wealthy isn't it if you excrete gold
this is quite an experience it's the
setting oh oh one thing that I want to
mention the cutlery is magnetic Conway
how we get this so you don't where you
taste the venison and then there's this
very slight bitter II sweetness it must
come from the chocolate you're not
really used to encourage really no no
incredible fusion at the end of the day
any food that is nice bread and
something to dip it in or eat it with I
don't think you can go wrong yeah wait
honest
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
worth it wintertime so obviously all the
restaurants were incredible but we have
to decide which was the most worth it my
worth winner has to be vanaras it was a
courier with little gold in it why
wouldn't it be the work that women I did
like Banaras a lot
I did like nazzer all a lot but my
favorite is Karuna I loved it the street
Mart I just felt very cool getting food
from a street market a little bit hip
don't what was yours that's wrong that's
wrong a little tomato on the top the
Crown King of the curry
mwah mwah it was like wow wow oh
don't blow afterwards wait I think we
got through first episode and then we
did it
nice one lads hope that was all right